let's go next to our caller from the
three one five area code who's calling
today from three one five three one five
all of a sudden is gone there you go
three one five is back dummy that's you
yeah hello yes okay my name is Dan I'm
from the Syracuse area hey Dan
so I'm it's kind of hard for me to word
this question but I I listen to you and
listen to secular talk Jimmy Dore you're
probably aware of those - yes but I'm
going to be removing your mention of
Jimmy Dore when we upload this just like
he did to Sam cedar because I can't have
his name being mentioned on my show yeah
okay so my question is basically there
seems to be a difference in your guys
view of the Mueller investigation and I
guess they they view it as more of
something that's counterproductive to
the progressive movement and they see it
as like a as kind of like an
establishment investigation or like
they'd say the deep state in which wait
a second look - secular talk is saying
is talking about the investigation is
the deep state I believe you mentioned
the word deep state but I do know he has
many videos on it and he is very
critical of the investigation he from
the beginning he said that there there
was a bunch of BS okay I want to be
really hard so listen I'm with peace and
love I'm not going to assume you're
accurately characterizing that only
because it's extremely hard for me to
imagine Kyle is talking about the deep
state as the source of the investigation
okay so maybe you can ask me what I
think about it but because I haven't
heard what either of these people have
said about it I would not be able to
respond to what you're saying they said
all right so yeah so let's say that he
didn't say deep state so basically I
guess my question is yeah what do you
think of the idea that it's counter to
counterintuitive to the progressive
movement or that for example if it was
if he would did the same thing with
Saudi Arabia there wouldn't be an
investigation and that for example
something he would say is that the only
reason that the investigation started
was because Trump was threatening to
pull out of Syria and you know that
that's sort of so I think it started
I don't think the timing I don't think
that that idea that the investigation
started because Trump was threatening to
pull out of Syria I don't think the
timing of that makes sense although I'd
have to look at the dates I guess I
would say to you in what way has the
investigation been counterproductive for
the progressive movement well personally
I would think that you know I think that
trying to impeach Trump on this issue is
not the issue he should be in people
know you know issue who's trying to
who's trying to jump on which issue on
the issue of him colluding with Russia
or the obstruction of justice issue okay
so our option of Justice Muller did find
that on eight of 14 counts Trump's
actions met all three legal requirements
to be obstruction do you agree or
disagree with that part like do you
agree that that's what molar said I I
did I did read the that there were I
thought there were 10 codes in which I
thought the wording was these could be
these could be classified as obstruction
of justice I think I think it was maybe
even 14 that could be obstructive and
then on eight and then on a droid
substantial evidence was found meeting
all three legal requirements on 8 of the
14 or eight of the 10 so you agreed
you're not disputing Moeller's finding
there no I wouldn't just be this finding
so I guess my position would be that I
think when it comes down to it that's a
Russia investigation was something that
I think it's counterintuitive because I
think that there's actual things that
Trump is done that are more will more
willing to have him be impeached for
like for example what's going on in
Yemen and I think that it's kind of a
distraction and I think the only reason
that it's such a big deal especially
with a lot of people from the
establishment is that it's Russia so for
example like my point was that you know
let's say that Hillary had done the same
exact thing that Trump did but with
Saudi Arabia that's not the right but
listen I'm 100% with you the Yemen stuff
is impeachable and I have a video saying
aside from everything in the Russia
probe Trump should be impeached for the
Yemen stuff so I'm completely with you
there but when peep
start going into if Trump did this with
Saudi Arabia or if Hillary did that with
Saudi Arabia I mean listen there were
the basis for this investigation is now
widely established and the investigation
happened it's now done it's over we've
got a report we want to publicize the
content of the report and people can
make of it what they will
right so would you agree then though
that his actions with Yemen are more
egregious than with Russia and that it's
it's not necessarily a good thing that
his things with Russia are getting more
attention from the media production are
you talking about collusion
so I guess both of those just everything
with Russia like the whole house inky
this the whole treason thing just like
the entire tree you're all over the
floor I'm not there's I don't even know
that treason is mentioned in the molar
report so listen here's my view and I
got a runoff I think the Yemen stuff is
a disaster it's totally different than
the obstruction stuff
they're both serious I think there are a
number of bases on which you should have
impeachment inquiries and I think that
that that's basically you know as far as
I can get on on it right now
okay well thank you all right appreciate
your call uh man just just all over the
place it's hard to we got to focus in
you know what I mean